a rift continues to grow between the
local forces of the Saudi UAE coalition
after dozens of their soldiers were
killed in a Houthi attack last week
southern separatists blamed the
internationally recognized government of
President Abdullah Mansour Hadi of
failing to protect them and called for
Hadi's government to be overthrown with
fragile negotiations taking place to
bring an end to Yemen's war the United
Nations is calling on the parties to
stand down we're very concerned about
the the ongoing violence that we're
seeing in in Aden this is something that
the special envoy himself has has stated
it is important for everyone to recommit
themselves to a political process Hadi's
government has support from Saudi Arabia
the southern secessionists led by a
truce Elsa Bedi are backed by the United
Arab Emirates while the Emiratis
announced their withdrawal from Yemen
last month they've armed trained and
left behind 90,000 troops made up of
fighters from southern communities and
the coastal plains that opens up the
prospect of a new front line between a
UAE backed force against the Saudi
backed government it's gonna be very
dangerous they are on the same side in
terms of fighting the ho see or a No
northern opponent out however in reality
they have not been getting along for
months and the southern separatist
forces especially represented in the
southern transitional council have
called repeatedly to secession and feel
like the time is ideal to
self-determination and to pursue it now
so it seems that although they're
fighting against a common enemy the time
has come where differences amongst them
are more important than just fighting
that enemy the area where the fighting
is taking place is the highest point in
the city and near the presidential
palace and even though the building is
largely empty it's still considered the
seat of government without a resolution
to their long-standing demands southern
separatists may decide to try and take
their seat at the negotiating table if
one isn't given to them Andrew Chappell
al Jazeera
live now to Senna and Al Jazeera's
Mohamed Al Attar who's there first this
our Muhammad as to this new front
opening up in Aden just get us right up
today what's the latest information you
have yes the confrontations continue
despite that the after the its he began
the the people there left shortly left
for a little bit ceasefire but now but
in the afternoon of the yesterday they
continued their first confrontations up
to now these the confrontations continue
and also escalates especially and in the
in the areas between crater and wala and
atewa Heath Allen and Hawaii are they
were the biggest concentration of
population there most of the rights
activists are concerned about the lives
of civilians there many appeals have
been also issued by civilians wha
suffering from chronic diseases because
the the situation is getting there
dangerous for them to stay trapped
between both fighting sites also the
confrontations continue and be in the in
the area between Lahore Maxo
where were the the presidential palace
as situated at least 11 people have been
killed according to some sources but we
cannot confirm the death toll to now
because the first confrontation is still
going on and there's a difficulty to to
check how many people have been being
killed during these confrontations no I
mean thanks very much